et notre reporter thomas bonnin suit
également le rassemblement tout de suite
le point avec lui énormément de monde
rassemblés sur cette place de la
république avec beaucoup de personnes
qui sont arrivées depuis maintenant une
heure et demie deux heures ici sur 7 sur
cette place à l'heure initialement la
manifestation se devait se diriger en
direction de la place de l'opéra mais en
fait les gendarmes bloquent la tête de
ce cortège en tête du cortège il ya
notamment les organisateurs à ça traoré
entre autres et ils ont tenté de
négocier avec les gendarmes pour qui les
laisse continuer leur chemin en
direction de la place de l'opéra mais
ils ont essuyé plusieurs refus est tout
à l'heure un des organisateurs a pris la
parole pour expliquer qu'ils allaient
rester finalement sur cette place de la
république ils sont bien décidés à faire
entendre leurs revendications malgré
cette interdiction de dernière minute
dans ce cortège il ya donc beaucoup de
monde beaucoup de personnalités
politiques personnalités publiques
également et puis tout à l'heure il ya
eu un point de tension lorsque des
militants du groupe génération
identitaires ont déployé une banderole
sur un des immeubles qui est sur cette
place de la république une banderole sur
le racisme anti blanc est évidemment
lorsqu'ils ont déployé cette banderole
cela a provoqué des tensions au sein de
la foule et finalement ce sont des
voisins qui habitent l étage en dessous
où était située cette banderole qui on a
découpé l'affiché qui ont évidemment
provoqué la des applaudissements de la
part de la foule depuis les îles et
angles génération identitaires sont
toujours sur le toit de cet immeuble et
ils sont régulièrement conçu et vous
l'imaginez par la foule présente en très
grand nombre ici